[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore
les gars là hélas j'interprète tous les
jours francis cabrel et l'âge d'or lui
pouvait nous faire du coup de fraude
fiscale mais alors attendez je réfléchis
à la chanson que je vais m'orienter
bonjour messieurs mais vraiment je vais
pas vous faire ce que je vais vous faire
maxime le forestier pas d'accord allez
l'habitude de nous joue des tours nous
qui pensions que notre amour avait une
santé de fer
le pechoux decoster la romieu ce sera
pesé sur la musique et sur mes vers l
teinte bien les feuilles d'automne où
vous n'étiez pas né vous donnons la
patrouille s'est passé depuis l'une
chanson sur l'usure du couple
voilà alors voici le premier jouer chez
vous et sophie davant qui mitent on a
tous envie de voir ça les parties vous
surprenez chers amis bonjour merci vous
étiez très nombreux
c'est parti
ségolène si vous ne regardez
pardonnez-nous attention un point pour
vous le deuxième est